i've always tried to you know keep it
professional and the people i worked
with i must say
did as well matthew mcconaughey might be
the ultimate rom-com
leading man well thank you that it comes
off that way
but off-screen he says he's always kept
it totally profeshed with his on-screen
love interests
the 50-year-old actor opened up on
siriusxm's the howard stern show about
why he's
never gotten romantically involved with
his co-stars
some of whom include kate hudson our
love fern
it's dead
[Music]
no honey it's just sleeping you let it
die
jennifer lopez are you okay you saved
my show and my life jennifer garner
connor mead jenny perrotti and sarah
jessica parker
you don't mind that my parents are
downstairs right now they're asleep
maybe we had certain crutches on each
other at certain times but we always
just kind of kept it professional
or maybe we were dating somebody
seriously um
outside of ourselves at the time and we
both respected that for the other
and matthew explained why he wanted to
keep it strictly business
you look at the history of films when
you see a couple if a couple like
you'd say they did a movie together and
then later on they get married right
and they make another movie together
watch the movie
when they're with them when they're
really good is the movie before they
before it was ever public that they were
getting together and
when they're on the approach that you're
going oh offset they got a little
honeymoon now but once they get married
you watch that movie they're like oh
they're not near as good to get it
yep keep it platonic for the sake of the
art
it's the movie when they met yes
there you go true that's the one that
this thing is sizzling
e.t recently chatted with kate hudson
who co-starred with matthew and how to
lose a guy in 10 days in 2003.
you call my bluff
you bet i am and fool's gold in 2008
i'm so glad i'm not married anymore and
she confirmed those epic romantic af
make-out scenes were all smoke and
mirrors
with mcconaughey we always end up in
these really extreme situations where
like the kissing is never like a good
environment like we're either like after
a plane crash and like in the water and
there's nothing everybody thinks i'm
gonna say matthew every time that
happens but
i have yet to have the kiss with matthew
that's just like
kind of simple
[Music]